Hi
I don't let this shortcoming
limit my steps forward to
pursue my dreams
I hope that all people
don't just see my flaws
we see my work
Hi hi my name is Zulkarnain I'm
a photographer
I was born without hands and feet  I
chose to be a photographer at first
I became an ID card photographer in
my village and I thought photography was
interesting
[Music]
I used a small Bukat car which
I called the F1 car, I
chained it myself, designed it myself and that
car took me everywhere  where until
now
Hi
maybe
I used a camera
with one of the meats that was still
given by God so I left this
meat and meat which I used
to
press the shutter then
I used my left hand to hold the
weight of the camera
[Music]
My photos were published  maybe not
only in Indonesia but also yesterday there were
several international media  onal
Then there are some photos of me
that were published in Turkey, my followers are
almost there. I want to help
friends who have the desire
to learn photography. I hope
that those who get photography inspiration are
not only people in
normal quotes but friends with
disabilities
[Music  ]
but I'm proud
of my limitations
I think I'm disabled but
I'm not a disabled person
but I'm just a person who
[Music]
woe woe